you let yourself go to sleep your
resistant drops so it's everybody has a
has a limit of resistance until the you
know to resist a choke before you pass
out the moment that you you you go to
sleep that resistance will dropped
that's why I've never heard anyone say
yeah that's awesome so that's true so
tap this so that's the reason because
people usually say it's no it's the same
or you're getting knocked out you get
knocked out the first time your
resistant dropped your drug a week gets
weaker so just for the record I've never
gone to sleep again
which uh means my resistance is high
right I don't know it must be oh your
defense is pretty good I I don't know
about that no no I would
um because it doesn't make sense to me
or maybe
in my case I think my understanding of
when I'm screwed is pretty good yeah
like there's no you're not in trouble
yeah one of the things I regret the most
about my Jiu Jitsu journey is not having
given enough time to um
being in really bad positions like the
better I got I think the less I started
being in bad positions
that's like the that is how you train
yeah because you used to just Spa When
You Spa like it's difficult to to be in
bad positions a lot you train with
better people but I mean let's say five
six minute rolls how long you're going
to be in a really bad position not long
right so you don't really have time to
develop
that's why people they don't
you know they don't train be in bad
positions because you have to stop there
over and over again
to be used to it yeah or put yourself
there I just didn't have that mindset I
think I think you start I mean part of
the fun of jiu jitsu's as you get better
and better you have certain people you
go with you have these puzzles that
you've figured out that you're playing
very specific details you're working out
you're trying to improve your main
like techniques and so on but yeah just
the percentage of time you spend being
submitted or being or trying even going
against like Laura ranks trying to
escape basic submissions slow I I don't
know if that's true for most people
probably is right most people have very
bad defense yeah because they don't
allow themselves to be there because
I mean who wants to get tapped because
you will until you you know to work on
your defense of course you're gonna get
tap or you know you're not gonna Escape
you're gonna struggle to escape
so people they don't want to be there
I regret it most because of the effect
it clearly had and how I competed
it it was it was clear that my
competition was it was constantly driven
by a conservative thinking
like don't take risks I think because of
a weak defense honestly and I think uh a
lot of the any of the fear like uh for
example exhaustion was accompanied by
fear because of weak defense I think if
I were to psychoanalyze myself and I
regretted it I regret it a lot